hier nochmal kurz produktfoto von der
seite wo war einmal wieder eingeblendet
und originale absolut identisch oder und
herzlich willkommen bei nochmaliger
toskana und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja hatte ich hoffe
natürlich dass gut heute endlich ein
video ich freue mich richtig drauf weil
ich muss sagen dass es gefühlt der
größte wunsch von euch dass ich endlich
mal ein video dazu mache und zwar bei
allen videos wenn ich wieder bei uns
bestellt hat bei amazon bei human oder
was es sonst noch so viele treiber
richtig viele leute hier jemand haare
alle bestellen x bow wow wo war es wohl
so eine neue plattform die ähnlich wie
wisch und jugend funktioniert also da
gibt es auch ermöglichen china kamen
alle möglichen sachen fakes und so
weiter und ich habe da vor über einem
monat sachen bestellt das problem ist
dass hat noch eine längere lieferzeit
gehabt als bayerisch sowieso also ich
habe allein auf dieses paket über einem
monat gewartet und es ist jetzt aber
endlich mal angekommen deswegen ich bin
extrem gespannt ob dieses ding hier
diesen dingen hier konkurrenz machen
kann weil die hat wahrscheinlich am
titel schon gelesen ich habe also ein
paar sachen ausgewählt erstmal um da
reinzukommen die plattform so ein
bisschen kennen zu lernen die halt
allgemein gut nutzbar sind also die
viele viele leute nutzen und habe dann
halt so sachen wie playstation
controller handys airports und so weiter
bestellen und ja ich würde sagen wir
ladung gar nicht lange shack mal kurz
das produkt ab hier auf meinem macbook
ich bin euch das gern noch mal zeigen
weil hier muss man wirklich sagen das
sieht eins zu eins aus wie das original
zumindest auf den fotos und das schauen
wir uns jetzt mal ab aber du solltest in
zukunft nicht so weite oberteile tragen
weil das zu weiß das video ich bin zur
farbe der coole leute irgendwie total
komisch auf meinem macbook wenn ich
darüber ins internet gehe ist das
produkt ausverkauft jetzt habe ich ihn
allerdings hier war mein handy gefunden
wir nehmen mal kurz zum bildschirm auf
also ich bin ja auf der meine bestellung
und genau hier habe ich für 21 euro 96
einen playstation com
dollar bestellt wir gehen mal drauf und
hier kann man sehen und guck mal da
kostet jetzt sogar schon 25 euro 25 man
kann aber sehen von dem produkt fotos
sind das eins zu eins aus wie ein
finaler playstation controller was
kostet der heutzutage 40 euro 40 euro
oder sogar mehr
ich guck mal gleich kurz nach auf jeden
fall ja da bin ich wirklich mal gespannt
weil man muss auch dazu sagen ich habe
vor einem halben jahr oder so mal diesen
controller bestellt bayerisch der hat
ungefähr das gleiche kostet ich glaube
sogar ein bisschen mehr hat halt nur 17
euro gekostet gut so viel bisher
wir machen das mal auf der fei
controller erinnert mich von der form
her ein bisschen an den xbox controller
zumindest xbox 360 hatte ich vor meiner
playstation und den benutze ich bis
heute das ist doch eigentlich ganz geil
bis auf der akku hält nicht ganz so
lange wie bei den originalen kontrollen
das video könnt ihr euch sehr gerne auch
nach diesem video anschauen wir haben
jetzt zwei bewertungen irgendwer war ich
zufrieden und hat einfach einstellungen
geben
gut ich bin mal gespannt ob ich mich dem
anschließen oder ob das ding
funktioniert werden sehen deswegen
packen das jetzt mal aus ich habe da mal
nachgeguckt und ein originaler
playstation controller kostet 50 bis 55
euro kommt auf die fahrbahn lenken was
solche mit dem messer mal wie ein
professioneller youtuber an boxen macht
das gut und das ist dann wie klein
gefahren vor allem folgen jetzt hier
nochmal kurz produktfoto von der seite
wo war einmal wieder eingeblendet und
original absolut identisch oder also das
grenzt ja schon an verarsche oder weil
die werden hier mit einem original
produkt ist ja ganz klar google die
kasse
ja deswegen ja das sieht das sieht also
hier dürfen wahrscheinlich nicht im
kreis drauf malen weil es
urheberrechtlich geschützt ist
genauso wie hier bei dem der war jetzt
von misch da sind das ja auch etwas
andere zeichen aber hier sind wir halt
ganz total anders wahrscheinlich weil es
so viele fakes schon gibt und man muss
immer irgendeinen muster finden was es
noch nicht gibt oder war gut
diane böses
das machen jetzt mal auf kabel haben wir
schon mal dabei
das finde ich gut das ist doch ziemlich
lang ich habe mich wirklich nur noch
sagen ganz kurzes aufgabe kam für meine
playstation controller ja also da und
würde ich schon mal zufrieden
danke dafür und jetzt bei den
controllern konntest du in verschiedenen
farben kaufen oder nicht kaufen
ich konnte in blau rot weiß und grün
getroffen und schwarz blau rot weiß und
was genau und ich habe mich halt für
blau entschieden wobei man muss halt
auch sagen das gibt mir von playstation
dann komplett blauen kontrolle der hier
ist ja hinten schwarz also gut ich weiß
jetzt einfach mal alles ab so schoss
folien sind alle also hier haben jetzt
einmal den originalen controller und den
fei controller sehen gleich aus
oder siehst du den unterschied das geht
echt also ich finde das passt eigentlich
jetzt hör mal du nicht anders als den
unterschied ja gut
ja stimmt wie fühlen sich die tasten
dann muss sagen tasten fühlen sich
eigentlich leicht also finde ich nicht
schlecht an
ich würde fast sagen ja eigentlich
komplett gleich also das muss man sagen
ist ein wirklich vom design her eins zu
eins gleich außer hier unten auf den
zugang für mikrofon und so ich weiß aber
gar nicht wie das bei den ganz aktuellen
playstation controller ist ob durch das
überhaupt noch haben so keine ahnung
mehr gut
das wichtigste ist den erst mal
auszuprobieren dafür müssen wir ein
zimmer gehen und dann bin ich mal
gespannt ob das funktioniert weil wenn
es funktioniert hat man ja immerhin 25
euro gespart und hat eigentlich ein
controller der in ordnung ist fehlt halt
nur die playstation oder was sonst immer
mal mein zimmer ne aber ein bisschen
unheimlich
in allem okay ich würde sagen wir
schließen einfach mal an du bist du
zufrieden mit den bildern hier mit den
bildern
also ich hänge die auf jeden fall wieder
ab weil maria angst vor den bildern füße
an weil sie meinte diesen großen nicht
einmal darauf verstehen oder die haben
wirklich neuen euro kostet werden die
letztens in dem video ich bin von meinem
zimmer mit milchprodukten check das auf
jeden fall ab aber das war so das
schlechteste verein und die schönsten
sind auch weg ja immer die sind allein
die schäden seien alle abgefallen und
jetzt klebt dann auch diese scheiß
kleber an der wand aber du weißt du als
5000 daumen hoch bekommt und fünf wochen
pause
und ganz wichtig schreibt auch hier in
die kommentare
welche sache nicht noch bei bucher
bestellen soll ja würde mich darüber
freuen
jetzt machen wir erstmal die playstation
und dann natürlich auch bestenfalls ein
controller kann leuchtet sieht man das
fernsehen machen wir auch nicht schlecht
hier meine fernbedienung habe ich auch
ganz klassisch in der frisch
fernbedienungs hülle eingepackt kann
funktioniert einwandfrei
doch hat funktioniert das ist doch
wirklich das hässlichste ding christen
es gibt ja ich bin so gut
das schützt vor es schützt verstaubt so
playstation ist an direkt verbunden also
das was jetzt gespielt also ich hab mal
größer ist fifa an gemacht ich muss
sagen bis jetzt funktioniert richtig gut
wie ein richtiger playstation controller
als ich merke keinen unterschied bis auf
das visuelle weißt du siehst du hier die
knöpfe die sind da ganz anders aus aber
sonst bin ich total zufrieden also für
21 euro kann man sich auf jeden fall
nicht beschwert wie der jetzt gleich im
spiel agiert weil man muss schon sagen
fifa kann ich eigentlich ganz gut und
das habe ich auch schon lange gespielt
und ich merke wenn ein controller
scheiße ist das ist das merke ich direkt
deswegen problem das noch kurz und dann
ist das video eigentlich schon vorbei
berichtigung vielfalt kannst du nicht
gut
natürlich für dich reicht ja allemal
natürlich wir können ja gleich eine
runde spielen
[Musik]
also ich glaube war die jetzt immer noch
kurz im spiel
[Applaus]
ja
das funktioniert nicht der tod
funktioniert funktioniert ist ja das
wäre toll gewesen funktioniert nicht der
hat funktioniert also schon zweimal
bronze
na gut ich spiele auch nur
fortgeschrittene modus also muss richtig
hart drücken dass er funktioniert das ja
scheiße also durchgefallen
das helfe oder also es kann ja nicht
sein muss
heißt es
aber das funktioniert auch wenn du
wirklich richtig hart drauf drückt das
gefilmt würde ich darauf gehofft
na gut naja also wenn man halt einfach
mal ein controller braucht zum
navigieren wenn man irgendwelche serien
über die playstation kurvenbereich tja
und wenn du wirklich zocken willst ist
er nicht gut ich weiß natürlich auch
dass bei dem es eine ausnahme ist aber
das ist von der qualität her
man hört ja auch da ist irgendwas locker
also ich muss sagen der liegt wirklich
innerhalb vier ein originaler
playstation controller fühlt sich so an
und die tasten sind auch wirklich
hochwertig aber wenn sie nicht
funktionieren einwandfrei ist das
natürlich schade und ich wollte schon
sagen wer ist auf jeden fall besser als
dieser controller von bush weil er ein
bisschen billiger ist das merkt man ganz
klar aber die tasten funktionieren bei
dem von gestellt alle deswegen würde ich
sagen konnte leider durchgefallen oder
schreibt aber auf jeden fall noch
weitere ideen was ich dort noch so
bestellen soll in die kommentare
ist superwichtig oder bei instagram 30
alexy ansonsten abonniert den kanal
kippen doch nach oben blog aktivieren
wir sehen uns morgen meist nur wieder
gibt's neues video haut rein